Добрий день дорогі друзі вітаємо всіх
хто дивиться нас онлайн Сьогодні ми
зібралися аби презентувати посібник як
говорити в школі про
російсько-українську війну уроки
стійкості боротьби та перемог Мене звати
Антоніна Макаревич Я співавторка
посібника і модеруватиму цей захід
сьогодні з нами Міністр освіти і науки
України оксен Лісовий генеральний
директор директорату шкільної освіти
Ігор хворостяний кандидат історичних
наук науковий співробітник інституту
історії України офіцер збройних сил
України Олександр алфоров кандидат
історичних наук автор підручників і
посібників співавтор цього посібника і
офіцер збройних сил України Олександр
Бана
а також з нами онлайн сімейна і дитяча
психологиня розробниця матеріалів
посібника Світлана Рось а також
Олександр Охріменко кандидат історичних
наук вчитель викладач і співавтор цього
посібника найперше Ми хочемо подякувати
силам оборони України завдяки яким ми
маємо можливість бути тут Ми дякуємо
нашим захисникам волонтерам вчителям
медикам дипломатам вченим рятувальникам
усім тим хто своїми діями наближає
перемогу України і прошу вшанувати
хвилиною мовчання всіх Хто віддав своє
життя за Україну у війні Росії проти
України прошу
встати
запрошую до слова міністра освіти і
науки України пани Оксана лісовога
Міністерство освіти і науки стартувало
запустило цей проект Розкажіть будь
ласка чому важливо говорити про війну
Росії проти України у
школі Дякую Антоніно Дякую всім колегам
які долучилися до розробки е цього
матеріалу він надзвичайно важливий
сьогодні є для системи освіти чому
ее всі ми проживаємо
ее події історичні події які
відбуваються сьогодні
ее в нашій країні Ну і мають глобальне
значення
проживаючи їх ми бачимо їх під своїм
кутом зору ми бачимо ту ділянку ту
частину історичного процесу яка доступна
нам і це стосується як педагога дорослої
людини так і підлітка і дитини і
молодшого школяра і навіть дошкільника е
Сьогодні весь український народ є
учасником історичних подій Але чи е
бачить Кожен громадянин України цілісну
картину
чи має він широту сприйняття і глибину
осмислення тих подій які відбуваються
сьогодні з нашою
країною чи систематизоване його знання і
розуміння Це ті
питання на які власне єсть відповідь ні
в будь-якому разі погляд кожної людини є
суб'єктивний людина проживає свій досвід
людина бачить частину
процесів і у ввідомлює частину процесів
тому завданням освіти є сформувати у
громадянина України засобами освіти
цілісну картину дати громадянину України
усвідомлення важливості
і першопричин тих подій які відбуваються
в
Україні
прив'язати рішення які приймають на
рівні як особистості так і на рівні
всієї держави до ціннісних орієнтирів
показати як
корелюється власне та та ціннісна
парадигма той ціннісний вибір який
робить наша країна в як імплементується
вона в щоденних рішеннях як на
політичному рівні так і на
індивідуальному
рівні все це
е можна і потрібно здійснити засобами
освіти тому одним із перших кроків
наших є створення цих методичних
рекомендацій для педагогів які покажуть
по-перше зорієнтують педагога в тому які
аспекти слід
ее представити своїм учням Як
сформулювати цю цілісність в сприйнятті
е-е тих реалій в яких ми перебуваємо як
е сформувати оті е оту
пов'язаність історичну пов'язаність
пов'язаність
з
певною певним політико-історичним і
суспільно-історичним вибором який
зробила Україна і робить Україна власне
борючись сьогодні за свою незалежність
дати розуміння за що конкретно ми
боремось і чому ця боротьба важлива для
кожного з нас І дуже важливо
дати контекст успіху в цій боротьбі тому
що я не втомлююсь повторювати одну річ
укра уїна є суперуспішною країною
Україна - це країна яка перебуваючи в
оточенні агресивних імперій не тільки
зберегла свою державність вона зберегла
свою ідентичність вона зберегла свою
культуру вона зберегла свою мову і
попри мабуть безпрецедентні
е репресії
які застосовувались до нашої нації до
нашої культури до нашої мови ми не лише
витримуємо цей тиск ми розвиваємо на
кожному новому історичному етапі ми
розвиваємо всі ці обов'язкові складові
нашої національної ідентичності якщо ми
говоримо про нашу державу ми піддалися
безпрецедентній атаці другої армії в
Світі але при цьому всі наші державні
інститути вся наша економіка
е вистояла і функціонує та частина
країни яка е-е не перебуває
безпосередньо на лінії фронту працює е-е
економіка тим не менше попри колосальні
виклики які стоять перед країною
рухається вперед державні інституції
функціонують реформи здійснюються Ми
кожен день на всіх фронтах як на фронті
е-е безпосередньо військовому так і в
економіці в зовнішній політиці е в у в
утвердженні
е громадянських інститутів досягаємо
перемог Перемоги перемог е Тому нам дуже
важливо щоб кожен вчитель
ее мав інструменти які допоможуть йому
сфокусувати увагу учня на цих складових
на цих успіхах на цих перемогах на цих
досягненнях але і на тих е катастрофах
фактично які попри які ми досягаємо цих
успіхів на прояви геноциду на прояви
нетерпимості культурної в тому числі
нетерпимості
на на безпрецедентні атаки на
енергетичну систему на банківську
систему на кібератаки і дуже важливо
знову ж таки щоб
Вчитель дав
розуміння
учневі щодо того
чому ми боремось чому це важливо чому
оті та система цінностей яку ми
відстоюємо важлива і вигідна для кожної
людини для її індивідуального
персонального успіху чому важливо мати
свою державу чому важливо вміти її
захистити чому це вигідно персонально
для кожного громадянина і кожної родини
чому демократична модель суспільна біль
ефективна і успішна в майбутньому світі
ніж тоталітарна Чому ми повинні
здійснювати цей спротив ось такий такий
інструмент власне значною мірою
міститься в цьому посібнику і друга
складова психологічна стійкість люди
виснашені діти підлітки переживають так
само болісно е всі ті події Вони
знаходяться в тому ж інформаційному
просторі що і дорослі і так само болісно
пережива ю всі ті події які відбуваються
навколо них
але на противагу дорослій людині яка
уже сформована як особистість Вона має
набір інструментів для самореалізації
набір відповідних свобод Вона може піти
воювати Вона
може почати волонтерити Вона може
допомагати різними способами людям
навколо себе і самореалізовуватися в
цьому і гармонізовуватись з цією бідою і
знаходить роль для себе в цій біді в
протидії ї підліток і дитина не має цієї
свободи і тому дуже важливо дать їй оцю
опору допомогти сфо сформулювати
сформувати в ній оцю психологічну
стійкість і витримати цей виклик і вийти
з цього Випробування сильнішою сильнішим
громадянином більш усвідомленим більш
е який про пройшов через Ці випробування
і е став не вони Його не зламали а
зробили його відповідно сильнішим це
важливо для нас і я сподіваюсь і
впевнений в тому що це напрацювання буде
дійсно допоміжним дуже помічним для
наших
вчителів для нашої системи освіти і ми
знову ж таки не зупиняємося на цьому
рухаємося далі пане оксане щиро вам
дякую і справді дуже важливий меседж
який містить цей посібник що учні не є
споживачами контенту не є споживачами
інформації А є співтворцями цього
контенту тому що ми не можемо оминати те
що ми всі знаходимося безпосередньо в
Епіцентрі цих подій пане Ігорю запитаю
вас про етапи створення цього посібника
як ми все це разом робили яка мета і пан
оксен вже про це зазначив Можливо ви
захочете щось доповнити на кого
зорієнтований Для кого зорієнтований цей
посібник Дякую щиро
Антоніно ви щойно сказали от про те що
посібник зокрема акцентує на тому що
учень не є споживачем контенту але я б
хотів наголосити
якраз так само і вчитель не є споживачем
А є співтворцем чи
співтворчинею того чи
іншого продукту контенту розмови діалогу
полілогу який він чи вона ведуть І
власне це цим і зумовлено таку
ціль посібника це надати якусь допомогу
і підтримку конкретно вчительству В тому
щоб такі діалоги започатковувати і
провадити і запрошувати до розмови і
мати
конкретний матеріал систематизований
матеріал історично вивірений матеріал
для того щоб ця розмова була ефективною
ее крім згаданого посібник містить ще
акцент на
певному виявленні опірності
інформаційній війні зокрема протидії
ворожій пропаганді протидії маніпуляціям
різного роду і пропонує ряд наративів
ряд того як вивірено таку розмову можна
провадити для нас дуже важливим був
момент і отой
принцип формату інтонацій у посібникові
і тому до авторського колективу я шалено
радий що була залучена і є залученою
Світлана ройз дитяча і сімейна
психологиня оскільки в тому складному
стані в якому Ми всі живемо зараз
надзвичайно
важливо виважено відповідні розмови і
діалоги провадити Я б ще хотів додати і
зокрема наголосити на тому що е посібник
не є
е
нормативно-регуляторним документом та
такою залізобетонною конструкцією яка
змушує і вимагає від
учителів провадити розмову Саме так і
саме в такому форматі якраз навпаки за
мету з авторським колективом ми ставили
і дуже уважно відпрацьовували щоб це
було запрошення знову ж таки до цього
діалогу і певні імпульси іціативи і тому
важливим тут є людський вимір і
конкретні історії Життєві
історії пов'язані з війною це не не лише
історії героїв які лунають з медіа які
безперечно так само важливі але це і про
своє близьке і ближнє коло і про
підставу до життєвого виміру історії в
громаді в школі Ну бо війна так чи
інакше Тор кається всього суспільства і
Ось на цьому акценті Я б також хотів би
наголосити ну і звісно скільки часу це
тривало це тривало і насправді я хотів
би подякувати щонайперше авторському
колективу за готовність
враховувати ось це полізвучання багато
голосся різних підходів за виваженість
за
намагання не перетворити це на
інструмент
ідеологічної пропаганди А як я вже
наголошував саме запросити до розмови
надати як писав Плужник колись та Для
вас історики майбутні наш білі рядки
холодних слів то мені здається що така
розмова має бути не рядками холодних
слів і ось цей от життєвий вимір цієї
історії якраз і спонукає і запрошує до
цього формату крім того ще раз наголошу
на практичності і
ужитковості посібника Який Ну про це ми
скажемо точно далі але структуровано і
адаптовано до різних вікових
категорій власне ее матеріал е не
обмежується самим паперовим варіантом
він виводить е на різні qr-коди
додаткові можливості презентації Тобто
ми намагалися створити комплексний
інструмент який
ее в непростий е час додаткового
навантаження для вчительства
розвантажить вчителів і допоможе їм
ефективно організувати роботу і на
останок кілька слів про те якою це має
бути робота це не обов'язково мають бути
лише уроки історії чи лише години е
традиційно ми їх називаємо виховними чи
години спілкування насправді матеріали е
не
регламентують час місце і формат
проведення я вірю в те що такі розмо
мови і і такі такі речі мають бути
ініціативними стимулювати мотивувати
запит учнівства з одного боку а з іншого
боку озброювати вчительство для того щоб
на цей запит відповідати і вірю що на
основі цих матеріалів постануть
е більше якісніше в межах всієї держави
і в межах роботи кожного вчителя і
кожної вчительки якісні національні
наративи на яких ми
безперечно зокрема хотіли закцентувати у
посібникові так На які ми спираємося і
йдемо впевнено до своєї Перемоги
розуміючи Де ми знаходимося в якій
ситуації е цей посібник поділено на три
частини навіщо що і як тобто навіщо
говорити Що говорити і як говорити Ми
запропонували певну таку комбінацію
матеріалів для початкової школи для
середньої і старшої але це є
рекомендації тому що хто найкраще може
знати учнів і учениць як не вчитель який
працює в цьому класі і вчитель
відповідно до запиту учнівства в
співпраці зі своїми учнями-ученицями
може скомбінувати власний урок наприклад
з частини навіщо проговорити Певний
момент з наві з частини що якийсь інший
і як вибрати Певний метод формат роботи
який запропоновано у підручнику і те про
що ви пане Ігорю сказали що є додаткові
джерела в кінці цього посібника ми ви
сли в список рекомендованих джерел
різноманітні і статті і книги і відео
які можна спокійно впевнено
використовувати на своїх уроках а також
наприкінці посібника вміщено такі
приклади уроки уроків майстерок з
протидії фейка там є три уроки для
початкової школи середньої і старшої
вчитель може використати безпосередньо
Цей урок абсолютно вільно або ж на
основі запропонованих уроків створити
власний і
пропрацювати той механізм як можна
протидіяти фейкам безпосередньо у своєму
класі Спираючись на матеріали які
викладено у цьому посібнику Тобто це
такий надійний помічник вчителя те що ми
намагалися створити щоби вчителю було
зручно і зрозуміло Це як з цим працювати
І справді зараз багато вчителів
запрошують військових в клас я таке
практикувала у своїй вчительській роботі
зокрема запросила Олександра панарі і ми
ви здивувалися тому що питання не
зупинялися жоден урок не завершився
вчасно тому що діти хочуть про це
говорити їм важливо А тим паче коли вони
бачать військового питання питань
мільйон я також чула про досвід різних
вчителів хто запрошує в якому форматі ці
зустрічі відбуваються і справді це
потрібно і запит іде найперше від учнів
і учениць і це ми хотіли підкріпити і
надати вчительству надійні матеріали Я
хочу запитати пана Олександра алфорова
про те як це працювати історику коли ми
живемо в Епіцентрі подій Ми не можемо
зараз визначити передбачити точно
наслідки ми не знаємо що що буде завтра
ми не знаємо що буде за 5 хвилин
ситуація може змінюватися часом
змінюється дуже швидко як історику Що з
цим робити
ми всі хто тут присутні історики Так Ми
не працювали в таких умовах коли ми
знаходимося безпосередньо під час війни
до 14-го року ми такого досвіду не знали
як це І чи могли би ці матеріали
з'явитися умовно в березні 2022 року
говорити про широкомасштабне вторгнення
чи могло би це бути Дякую панетоніно я
дякую ладачам і тим хто долучився до
цієї справи надзвичайно важливою Ну як
історик Я хочу сказати що дуже хочеться
що завтра десь в районі 15:40 Росію
капітулюю от Можливо пізніше можливо
раніше ми не знаємо але насправді От я
зараз дивлюся я прочитав матеріал
зрозуміло що з пдфом працювати взагалі
шикарно тому що відразу прямі лінки і ти
я мандрував мережею цих лінків але от
зараз сиджу і дивлюся на цю назву як
говорити про російсько-українську війну
в школі і я думаю ну правда було б круто
якби ми в 14-му році мали такий посібник
в 15-му в 16-му а бу круто щоб ми його
мали В 22-му році в січні Але одночасно
з тим скажу
що якби цей посібник вийшов раніше
наприклад 14-й 15-й рік він би мав
зовсім інші наприклад стратегічні цілі
він би і тактично
мав би зовсім інші орієнтири і і межі
досліджень мажі пропонованих матеріалів
зрозуміло що цей посібник не був
можливий минулого року і позаминулого
року він народився в час коли ми
побачили з вже з достатньо високого
пташиного лету чи дронного лету побачили
весь комплекс засобів сил які направлені
проти нас І це безперечно не тільки ті
та військова машина та потуга яка
створена російською державою Ну і
накопичена після чеченської кампанії і в
спадок советська ми говоримо про те що
сьогодні ми здатні говорити про ті речі
які визнані на міжнародних майданчиках
Тому цей посібник він одночасно є
посібником не тільки українським він
стає унікальним посібником для заходу
для Європи та країн західної цивілізації
європейської цивілізації Штати Канада
Австралія тому що це посібник
ґрунтується на конкретних часових
просторах повномасштабної війни
вторгнення і ми можемо абсолютно
дозволяти собі говорити про те що цей
посібник є унікальним в системі освіти
для вже
Європи післявоєнне після 45-го року це
перше друге це не запізнення те що він
вийшов зараз тому що я кажу він
став такий що має потребу такий що
вийшов і одночасно він є зрозумілим
Європейському читачеві і тут момент
такий що Знаєте якби цей посібник
потрапив наприклад в школу Ну я не кажу
про своїх дітей е але Наприклад якщо б
він потрапив в школу наприклад території
Правобережної України в 14-му році чи
західних територій він би не так
сприймався тут Давайте будемо все ж таки
з точності хірурга говорити про те що є
речі які треба нам скальперем різати щоб
ми всі це зрозуміли тому як говорити про
війну коли вся країна знає що таке війна
коли мій син Я дивлюсь його зошит він
пише не класна робота а Підвальна робота
кажу сва яка Підвальна робота Він каже
Та ми ж бомбосховище були під гімназією
іце правда вони це вони це розумієте
вони це сприймають вони це знають і тому
це дуже класно Я хотів би кілька
моментів сказати що мені було особливо
Цікаво дивитися на по-перше те як тут і
інтегрована історія
України в сьогоднішні
події звісно вони відповідають
тому процесу мето методичкам в розробці
підручників Я розумію що це дійсно
посібник який абсолютно інкорпоровану в
систему сьогоднішньої освіти і це
відчувається тому він є і одночасно
невідірваним від базової освіти а
водночас він є
новаторським Звісно нам ще з я як
історик скажу нам що своє робити і часто
ми пишемо історію ну знаєте чомусь ми
пишемо історію
Завжди враховуючи Фактор однієї держави
у нас не не так багато інкорпоровано дат
наприклад Чи події пов'язано з Угорщиною
чи з Румунією чи з Молдовою чи
Словаччиною чи з Польщею тиж це Білорусі
як ага москвити зробили те тете в нас
часто це є такий крін що ми часто
Досліджуючи історію в цілому начебто
розпові даємо що не так було з
москвитами у нас і це теж є такий момент
він зміниться бо ми зараз цю історію
будуємо і другий цікавий фактор про який
я хотів би наголосити це боротьба з
фейками я із задоволенням поширяв цими
лінками подивився почитав Це круто Це
цікаво прикладі приклади дуже цікаві
мені це сподобалося і скажу що мені в
цілому було цікаво його
дивитися чесно тому що в мене четверо
дітей Я розумію що що так чи інакше Троє
з них вже в цій системі освіти Троє з
них вже якби ми з ними не говорили про
це але є принаймні стіка позиція з
приводу на назви що війна є війною ми
зрозуміємо що війну ніхто нам не
оголошував і досі бо це звичайна
політика Російської Федерації за всі
часи їхнього існування але навіть мені
як батькові було класно і потрібно
прочитати це тож я би можливо би
завдячуючи тому що ми в цій кампаніїму
спікерів маємо в присутності пана
міністра очевидно що такі посібники Вони
мають бути запроваджені не тільки в
систему освіти а очевидно як на
позашкільною і очевидно що ці посібники
дуже потрібні будуть саме в соціальних
соціальній роботі з
батьками тому що зрештою це перший крок
який мені здається дуже вдалий як
історик скажу що
такі речі які є красивими коли книжку
хочеться з'їсти Значить вона вдалася Я
хочу її з'їсти вона смачна
видно ці речі потрібні як для шкільної
освіти так і позашкільної освітию такі
речі потрібні батькам тому що рецептури
На преликий жаль для батьків у нас і
досі не розроблене як говорити що
робити Я хотів би наголосити що можливо
в подальшому в цих посібниках з мо моєї
точки зору необхідно ти ще таку
компоненту як те що є
діти які позбавлені були долі які були
позбавлені батьків близьких рідних
батьків яких служать і це теж має
розроблятися але вже Очевидно в
партнерстві з іншими інституціями для
того щоби створити ще більше потужну
систему оцю пояснення війни
зрештою X століття Ми намагаємося
писнити дітям що таке
війна Дякую щиро дякую і справді меседж
такий що ми можемо розширити нашу
аудиторію і цікаво те що учні після
роботи в школі з цим посібником можуть
прийти додому і пояснити Деякі моменти
своїм батькам А це вже залучає їх до
такої особливої розмови і це може таке
таке відбуватися Школа може бути таким
осередком першоджерелом звідки діти
беруть цю інформацію як вони
опрацьовують є коментарі пані Світлани
Ройс я як це правильно робити і потім Це
можна нести додому і з цим працювати
далі це поширювати ш навіть помітив би
Коли почали діти Україну співати батько
наш Бандера так Та то вони прийшли з
своєю піснею зі школи так з колективу
прийшли додому і батьки
Треба ж пояснити хто такий Бандера і
зрештою почалось оце от Це дійсно процес
який вимагає ну зрештою загального
такого розуміння Таму
ю Дякую безпосередньо ми дійшли до
частини що говорити ми проговорили
навіщо говорити про війну Росії проти
України пане Олександре Розкажіть будь
ласка що знайдуть вчителі а вже наш
меседж розширений не тільки вчителі А
всі хто будуть працювати з цим
посібником що знайдуть у частині що що
говорити про війну е дякую пані Антоніно
Дякую Шановні колеги Що долучилися до
дискусії з приводу цього посібника перш
за все Коли ми створювали його і коли
думали що саме має там бути
орієнтувалися на запити суспільства
історія нарешті стала цікавою
суспільству а історичні знання стали
потрібними потрібними для боротьби з
російським ворогом потрібними для
розуміння За що ми боремося чому ми
боремося Чому ця війна в XX столітті в
центрі Європи на жаль стала можливою і і
як нам боротися надалі для того щоб не
повторити знову тих помилок яких На жаль
ми вже зазнали І власне і про ці помилки
Також ми говоримо і в цьому посібнику і
акцентуємо увагу але ми ще акцентуємо
увагу і на важливості вживання
правильних термінів коли ми задаємося
запитаннями що ж говорити на вживанні
терміну війна і розуміння того що війна
триває з 2014 року на розумінні того як
гібридна війна переросла в
широкомасштабну війну і чому все-таки є
правильність використання дефініції
широкомасштабна війна а не
повномасштабна війна для того щоб також
цю різницю розуміли І усвідомлювали е
багато що в посібник звісно не могло
увійти Чому Тому що основне завдання яке
ми перед собою ставили це зро робити
такі опорні точки і визначити
магістральні
напрямки того про що потрібно говорити з
учнями ученицями з дітьми різного віку а
говорити без сумніву потрібно і потрібно
говорити майже кожен день Чому Тому що
це переживання емоцій е дітей педагогів
батьків всього суспільства тому що уроки
можуть початися а можуть не початися бо
повітряна тривога е ті навчальні заклади
які мають можливості проводити уроки
вони проводять уроки в сховищах
проводять уроки онлайн хтось виїхав за
кордон і не так або по-іншому відчуває
те що
відбувається сьогодні безпосередньо в
Україні навіть ті хто в Україні в різних
регіонах також по-різному відчувають хто
ближче до лінії
фронту безперечно живе в інших умовах
ніж ті хто трохи далі від цієї лінії але
в першу чергу коли ми обирали про що
говорити Ми акцентували увагу саме на
емоційності з одного боку мова йшла про
те що треба переживати це треба
поговорити про це з іншої сторони було
важливо не перетнути межу тому що
історії кожної окремої людини а я
наполягаю на тому що про сьогоднішню
війну ми повинні говорити в двох
площинах зводячи їх до одного знаменника
це особисті історії і історія всього
українського суспільства українського
народу Української держави в боротьбі в
XX столітті за своє існування і в тій
тисячолітній боротьбі яка забезпечує нам
сьогодні власне це історичне знання і
історичне минуле коли ми говоримо і
намагаємося акцентувати увагу на тому що
говорити нам важливо показати також
тяглість цього процесу до 2014 року що
напад Росії на Україну насправді не був
вже таким неочікуваним і випадковим і те
що відбулося після е 22
лютого після лютого 22-го року теж є
певною мірою процесом послідовного
знищення українського суспільства
геноциду українського народу і є далеко
не історичною випадковістю а фактично
цілеспрямованою дією російської
советської імперської російської машини
проти України проти українського
суспільства і взагалі проти існування
Української держави як
такої розповідати про сьогоднішню війну
говорити про те що відбувається треба з
постійним історичним історичними
аналогіями в минулому часі геноцид не
перший війна не перша проти України
прагнення Підкорити собі Україну - це ну
фактично споконвічне прагнення
імперського світогляду Московського
петербурзького неважливо е коли ми
говоримо про сучасну війну варто
розуміти що вона складається е як з
поразок так і перемог і ми повинні
говорити про це і розуміти що війна - це
і трагедія історія і трагедій і це
історія виживання і історія успішного
виживання успішної боротьби все це є
складовою побудови нового світогляду в
якому буде виховуватися будуть
виховуватися прийтешні покоління нинішнє
покоління учнівства тут головне
забезпечити для нас було головне
забезпечити вчителя тим мінімальним
набором
е фактів знань ось цих от напрямків до
розмови тому що насправді коли ми
готували цей посібник
е виявили
кілька реальносте по-перше інформації
про війну насправді дуже багато Ми
живемо в інформаційну епоху але якість
цієї інформації звісно дуже різна і для
того щоб підготувати
ось ці магістральні лінії і оці опорні
точки довелося насправді опрацювати
величезну кількість різноманітних джерел
публікацій думок оцінок аудіо і
відеоматеріалів для того щоб забезпечити
вчителя зекономити йому час і дати
можливість цей час використати
безпосередньо не для підготовки до
бесіди до спілкування а саме для самого
спілкування це важливо тому що тримати в
собі ту реальність в якій ми живемо не
не говорячи про неї не ділячись своїми в
першу чергу емоціями дуже важко
е коли йде розмова жива розмова і на
цьому Ми наполягаємо що цей посібник
повинен бути саме таким закликом до цієї
розмови Вона
створює певний вже емоційний фон Вона
має допомогти поле легшити переживання
цієї війни ми дійсно не знаємо що буде
завтра ми дійсно не знаємо як вона
закінчиться Ми віримо в те що ми
переможемо Тому що на нашому боці правда
і ми боремося за своє з нашим російським
ворогом але війна триває про це теж
треба говорити Чому важливо для нас було
в частині що говорити робити акцент саме
на емоційній складовій на на жаль на
сьогоднішній день ворог має Своїх
агентів в
Україні і дуже
часто ми спостерігаємо і особливо на
територіях тимчасово окупованих як
освітяни переходять на бік ворога є
інформація від служби безпеки України
яка з'являється в засобах масової
інформації про те як діти не з власних
переконань а випадково можуть стати
інформаторами ворога і в тому числі для
нас Як для мене як для офіцера збройних
сил Важливо не допустити цього тому
ее акценти на ті складові е війни яка
триває саме емоційні складові важливі
для того щоб
е змусити вчителя учня ученицю пережити
ці емоції говорячи про про ці події не
замовчуючи їх для того щоб переживаючи
ці емоції все суспільство розуміло свою
відповідальність за те що воно може
принаймні не нашкодити сьогоднішній
реальності і сьогоднішнім веденням
бойових дій Це також важливо тому що
іноді незнання воно породжує більшу біду
ніж цілеспрямована якась діяльність
проти Української держави я щиро
не вірю в те що
е Ці діти учні так які своїми
несвідомими вчинками могли допомогти
ворогові робили це з внутрішнього
переконання я більше сподіваюся що це
було саме через незнання так от наше
завдання було убезпечити і залишається
убезпечити від цього незнання А для
цього треба певні інструменти і ми
намагалися якраз таки дати набір таких
інструментів при цьому залишаючи Бо для
мене як для вчителя важливо залишати
педагога в його академічній свободі тож
на що варто звертати увагу під час
розмов і мені дуже подобається оцей
меседж спілкування розмова а не просто
виклад певної інформації на що варто
звертати увагу варто звертати увагу що
це не може бути викладом інформації це
має бути емоційне
переживання тих ралій в яких ми живемо
варто звертати увагу в першу чергу на
особистий досвід в будь-якому колективі
в будь-якому учнівському колективі є
різний особистий досвід і говорити про
війну треба виходячи з цього особистого
досвіду тоді сприйняття і ці цих реалій
і наслідків
і можливих сценаріїв поведінки буде йти
безпосередньо від людини нам
головне зробити було нам головне було
зробити Таким чином аби е комфортність
цих матеріалів забезпечувала цікавість
самому вчителеві говорити про це і
говорити про це можна на уроках з різних
предметів це не обов'язково мають бути
предмети суспільної е-е галузі так
історичні гуманітарні предмети про це
можна поговорити вдумливо і навіть на
уроках математики або мистецтва та тому
що е війна не обходить жодну сторону
життя на жаль і ця розмова повинна бути
органічною Тоді вона не буде викликати
супротиву тому що сьогодні поки що
багато хто не готовий про це говорити
тому що рани свіжі втрати свіжі і вони
тривають і іноді Ми навіть не знаємо
ее чи 5 хвилин тому назад хтось з учнів
не дай Бог не дізнався що його рідні
близькі батьки брати можливо вже
загинули на цій війні і вчителю
доводиться з цим працювати Тому
найважливіше найперше розуміти своїх
дітей зрозуміти себе зрозуміти своїх
дітей і говорити про те що вони хотіли б
почути якщо в них є запитання на них
треба давати відповідь чітку дорослу
професійну відповідь і ми намагалися
дати той набір інформації який би
допоміг спрямував вчителя на шлях Як цю
відповідь дати Дякую Ми сьогодні дуже
багато говоримо про психоемоційний стан
як учнів і учениць так і вчителів і цей
посібник не міг би з'явитися без порад
коментарів сімейної і дитячої
психологині Світлани Ройс пані Світлана
зараз з нами онлайн тож пані Світлано
Скажіть будь ласка як варто говорити про
війну в школі як вчителям підготувати і
налаштувати себе Адже від від них лунає
дуже багато запитань як правильно це
зробити як поговорити і як не травмувати
своїх учнів і учениць Пані Світлано вам
слово так добре що у нас вже не виникає
питання чи взагалі говорити про війну Бо
раніше дорослі намагались Виключити цю
тему життя дітей якщо ми чогось
намагаємось уникнути це завжди
переростає в те з чим нам потрібно потім
більш ретельно
працювати є питання як говорити Ми
знаємо що у дітей немає своєї історії
своїх наративів про те що з ними
відбувається і якщо ми це не прояснимо
якщо ми не не скажемо що сталося на
емоційному рівні це провокуватиме
тривогу і діти будуть створювати
доступні для них пояснення чи живитись
російською пропагандою ми вчимось
говорити спокійно Ясно авторитетно
зрозумілою мовою із відчуття особистої
стійкості бо як говорити це не тільки
про слова які ми добираємо особливо в
складних темах темах що пов'язані з
травматичним досвідом ми знаємо що діти
уважніші до невербальних сигналів
тональності пози жестам наших емоцій
тому ми починаємо розмову тільки тоді
коли можемо витримати навантаження теми
у психологів в практиці є супервізія
особиста терапія і я би так хотіла щоби
у вчителів була можливість спертися на
когось хто може надати підтримку якщо є
складна тема чи складності в темі
мінімум який ми робимо Ми створюємо
рамку безпеки наша техніка безпеки це
безпечний простір де всім є місце де всі
нас бачать і чують і точно знають що до
них будуть уважні і ми маємо бачити всіх
дітей щоб швидко зреагувати якщо
інформація буде за складною ми займаємо
стійку зручну позу ми в першу чергу в
контакті зі своїми емоціями диханням це
може звучати дивно але діти будуть
реагувати на темп нашого мовлення на
темп дихання це безпосередньо впливає на
їх стан ми можемо чесно сказати що тема
яка зараз буде опрацьовуватися і для нас
самих складна це тільки додасть щирості
стосункам та до нашої
авторитетності ми починаємо розмову на
складну тему зі стабілізації з будь-яких
вправ руханок звичних для цього класу
ритуалів дії Щоб сфокусувати на
теперішньому моменті це може зайняти 5
хвилин уроку але цей внесок в можливості
сприйняття та емоційну безпеку та
стійкість дитини коли ми підбираємо
інформацію ми уважні до відеоматеріалів
та аудіо коли дитина переживає стрес їй
складно раціонально опрацьовувати
інформацію для дорослого наприклад те що
він бачить в новинах те те що вже
відбулося і це стосується архівних ма
ріалів те це те що вже минуло А діти що
живуть в стані хронічного стресу можуть
сприймати Це ці події як ті що
відбуваються Саме зараз і це буде
сприйматися як небезпека якщо ми обрали
використання архівних матеріалів відео
фото обов'язково потрібно наголошувати
що це минуло Ми зараз в нашому
202425 26 роках і окремий блок в
методичці якраз про те як запобігти
вікарній травмі травмі свідка
Важливо пам'ятати що у кожного з нас
свій перріг витримування сприйняття
інформації ми не можемо спрогнозувати
який саме образ в фільмі може видасться
непереносимим для сприйняття дитини і
саме стане тригером для неї коли ми
читаємо інформацію уявляємо собі щось ми
в більшості випадків Якщо у нас не було
досвіду травми не виберемо того що
нервова система не зможе опрацювати А
коли бачимо сформований якимось образ
він може стати для нас небезпе
ми не пропонуємо саме зараз під час
війни дітям вправ практик заключеними
очима перше діти в стані стресу
намагаються все контролювати і коли очі
закрити втрачається відчуття контролю
дитині може складніше зосередитись друге
якщо дитина з заплющеними очима і
пролинає сигнал тривоги це стане
додатковим стресовим навантаженням
реакція на тривога буде сильнішею
найпростіше ми можемо запропонувати
дитині вибір далі ми уважні до всіх
звуків мені здавалось очевидним що
вчителі не будуть використовувати на
уроках звуки вибухів повітряної тривоги
але вже з практики знаю що про це
потрібно нагадувати теж те що виявилось
важливим для нагадування ми не показуємо
мертвих тіл крові і намагаємося не
показувати кадрів руйнування взагалі в
презентаціях ми уникаємо картинок з
великою кількістю подразників деталей
гострих кутів червоного кольору все це
перезбуджує і так активовано
переактивовано лімбічну систему дитини
що відповідає за реагування на безпеку
Та взагалі за емоційне
реагування є ще одно правило чим
емоційніша інформація тим спокійніше
чіткіше і без емоційного підсилення ми
її
розповідаємо якщо в темі розповідій чи
текстах є щось Що може бути травмуючим
ми в цей момент не питаємо Що ти зараз
відчуваєш Які у тебе зараз емоції це
тільки підсилить емоційне сприйняття і
знов перезбудить нашу лімбічну систему
ми можемо сказати що у нас самих ця
інформація чи це що сталося викликає сум
Роздратування людь і так ми нормалізуємо
можливі емоції реакції дитини і
пропонуємо далі чи практику на
осмислення чи якусь дію конкретну дію
про дії зараз популярні творчі завдання
для дітей по типу конкурсів малюнків
діти малюють війну чи діти бачать війну
це дуже некоректно завдання вони можуть
стати ретравмуючими для дітей їх може
використовувати арттерапевт який знає що
робити заглибленням дитини в стане що
провокує війна ми можемо і маємо
пропонувати трохи інші практики
наприклад Намалюй свою силу Намалюй свою
мрію Намалюй Україну майбутнього нам
потрібно щоб дитина вийшла з уроку в
стабільному стані і з відчуттям саме
сили коли Ми обираємо практики в яких
дитина Має себе з кимось ідентифікувати
вжити чуюсь роль з одного боку таке
заглиблення корисно для розвитку емпатії
з другого нам потрібно подбати щоби
наприкінці уроку Вона вийшла з цієї ролі
щоб не насла тягар доступа іншої людини
це мож цьому можна запобігти як
повернувши дитині контакт з її тілом
наприклад простукати себе по тілу
повернути відчуття кордонів торкнутись
грудної клітини Ну наприклад сказати я
СВТ
багато запитань від вчителів та батьків
про хвилини мавчання в школах ми маємо
пам'ятати що у дітей своє сприйняття
часу а особливо коли є загальний фон
тривожності хвилина для дитини може
сприйматися як 15 хвилин і Сама ідея
хвилин пам'яті може знецінитись чи буде
пов'язано з супротивим нам потрібно
скомунікувати для дитини Навіщо це
взагалі потрібне І що саме вона може
робити в цю хвилину Ми даємо цінності
ції хвилини ми можемо запропонувати
практику подяки чи створити свій ритуал
для кожного класу свою практику і в
методичці є невеликий розділ саме про це
якщо в класі є діти які втратили
близьких важливо створити для них
можливість на класній годині чи на уроці
якщо вони самі захочуть чи будуть готові
розповісти про близьких розповісти про
те що для них самих важливо і так ми
будемо перетворювати табойовану тему
смерті на те що створює Відчуття
близькості і дає місце пам'яті та
почуття коли ми готуємо будь-яку
інформацією ми орієнтуємося на
сприйняття найвразливішої дитини цієї
вікової категорії і маємо знати що
робити щоб стабілізувати емоційний стан
дитини якщо я якась інформація стала для
неї тригером спровокувала емоційну
реакцію якщо ми побачили зміну в
поведінці дітей як ми це бачимо це
проявляється розфокусованому погляді у
зостига чи гіперактивності у частих
змінах поз униканні контакту
відволіканні посмішці що не відповідає
контексту розмови можливі сльози нам
потрібно зробити паузу і запропонувати
всьому класу стабілізаційні практики чи
техніки це можуть бути дихання чи може
бути практики на заземлення фокусування
на поточному
моменті загалом коли ми починаємо
розмову на складну тему ми її пробудовує
в трьох блоках перший блок загальний
блок Ми з нього завжди починаємося він
так і називається блок стабілізації це
ресурсний блок підготовка для розмови по
фіксація на поточному моменті на
близькості на нашій силі далі йде блок
Конфронтація це безпосередньо
опрацювання складної теми блок
інтеграції це блок в якому ми робимо
висновки в якому ми спираємося на нашу
силу в якому ми питаємо яку Ново силу
для свого життя Ти береш сьогодні із
собою нехай наша методичка додає сили і
для вчителів і для дітей і для
батьків ми поговорили про те навіщо
говорити Що говорити і зараз поговоримо
про те як варто говорити передаю слово
Олександру охріменку він з нами також
онлайн тож пане Олександре Розкажіть
будь ласка які матеріали вміщено у
частині як говорити про
війну Дякую за запитання коли ми
створювали частину посібника як говорити
з дітьми Ми намагалися показати якими
інструментами вчительство може
використовувати непрямі способи говорити
про війну Ми не хочемо в класі
ретравматизувати наше учнівство чи
нагадувати якісь події війни Ми хотіли
би краще показати як діти переживають
війну який їхній досвід ми
зосереджувалися на те щоби цей досвід
вивчити дітей а також навчити дітей осяг
осягати свої емоції і
переживання тобто вчитель за допомогою
наших завдань може поговорити з дітьми
на тематику дуже близьку до воєнної але
водночас зосередитися не на воєнних
подіях чи героїчних вчинках чи е інших
якихось деталях саме воєнних операцій і
воєнних дій А зосереджитись на те як
діти це сприймають як діти це
переживають і як дітям краще справлятися
в умовах війни з собою своїми емоціями
зрозуміти емоції інших і так далі в
цьому величезну роль відіграє мистецтво
і це саме та методика яка була
розроблена після Другої світової війни
коли почалася реабілітація дітей і
багато шкіл багато педагогів пропонували
різні методи арттерапії хоча ми
пропонуємо уже стандартні методи
педагогіки тільки з тематикою війни Коли
Через мистецтво можна перепрожити певний
досвід зрозуміти досвід іншого І
зрозуміти свої емоції але інколи
мистецтво є заважким для аналізу дітей
тому для молодшої школи ми пропонуємо
також ряд Ігор навчальних Ігор зокрема
ігри з техніки безпеки а також
проговорювати і багато комунікувати
середовищем навколо вміти висловити свою
думку свої почуття свої емоції коли коли
особливо дитина не може справитися з
чимось пане Олександре які техніки
завдання і форми роботи пропонуються у
посібнику і як їх варто
використовувати звісно ми в посібнику
навели кілька прикладів конкретних
завдань які уже реалізовані десь
наприклад походив в моїх черевиках від
музею емпатії там в вироблені певні
аудіоматеріали які можна прослухати
історії людей надягнувши їхні черевики
пройти одну милю довкола цього
невеликого музею але і наші ідеї те що
Можна реалізувати в шкільному варіанті
це крім записаних історій це можуть бути
листи може бути музей іграшок з
історіями але це залежить уже від
конкретної ситуації що хочеть досягти
педагоги в конкретному випадку але треба
пам'ятати що війна - це про кожного
історія кожного тут дуже важлива і
досвід пережити також дуже важливо це
головна ідея цих усіх ідей чи завдань чи
прикладів які ми навели в посібнику і
зрештою чого вчить досвід людства
це цікаве запитання чого ж вчить досвід
людства і ми знаємо кілька варіантів які
допоможуть нам справитися з цією війною
також війна супроводжує людство постійно
минулі покоління переживали війну вони
зуміли вистояти захистити себе і продов
вати свій розвиток Ми також це зробимо
українство неодноразово переживало
воєнні події військові втручання і так
далі І ми завжди вистоювали зуміли
захищати себе боротися за себе
відстоювати себе попри всі негаразди
другий урок який дає історія - це те що
війна рано чи пізно завершується і нам
треба розуміти що ми будемо робити після
війни і третє ми знаємо що війна - це
завжди травматич досвід Але ми не можемо
його оминати і не варто його оминати Ми
нарешті підходимо до того інструменту
щоб говорити про війну перепроживати
зрозуміти і рухатися далі
умовно знайти ту частинку яку ми
втрачаємо яка руйнується і як будувати
майбутнє і соціальні зв'язки і так далі
тому дві педагогічні технології тут є
найрозповсюдженішими або найважливішими
це педагогіка травми з однієї сторони це
конкретні розроблені вже інструменти
педагогами як працювати
з дітьми які пережили травму а також
інша частинка - це педагогіка Надії Ми
не можемо зосереджуватися тільки на
трагічних подіях ми маємо зрозуміти і
дати розуміння це дітям що буде після
війни як буде відбудова країни тривати і
яка роль дітей в цьому процесі тому
досвід людства нам тільки показує що е
позитивний якийсь напрямок ми можемо
взяти і проговорювати також це з дітьми
даючи їм певне натхнення надію бажання
бути в Україні будувати країну
долучатися вже зараз і розуміти що війна
ще триває але відбудова країни уже
розпочалась
щиро дякую спікерам за розмову Щиро
дякуємо всім хто долучився до трансляції
дивився нас онлайн Тож ми переконалися
що про війну говорити варто про війну
говорити важливо і з кожним днем ми
краще розуміємо як говорити про війну
наш досвід накопичується і стає Більш
впевненим цей посібник - це один з
кроків впевнених кроків як про це варто
говорити Закликаємо вчителів
користуватися цим посібником поширювати
про нього інформацію серед колег аби
разом впевнено йти до перемоги щиро Всім
дякую і слава Україні героям
слава